[Music]
pow
hello and welcome to gamespot after dark
we
now have as many episodes as anita
campbell green and roger daly have
dalmatians in disney classic 101
dalmatians
that was a long way of saying how many
episodes we have right it's so tight
boom
nah well you know it happens sometimes
it'll be like that
my name is more sane and i'm joined by
jean-luc hello
howdy gamers nope i can't say that
that's that's copyrighted
yeah that is an evan langer classic he's
not here um
he was gonna be on but he he can't so uh
i'm just gonna steal his bits
michael hyam how are you what are you do
baby i
am i'm doing terribly but you know what
i'm doing fine now because i'm here with
y'all because y'all my friends
hey also here with us is jordan remy
what's up ubisoft will not let me rest
yeah ubisoft will not let you rest and
team cherry will not
let you feel joy it's the it's the
pained existence of
jordan remay uh we celebrated our 101
first part 100th podcast last week now
we're in our 100th podcast and
we're kind of leaning starting to lean
back into video we're bringing a video
back
in in a way um so for those who have
been with us from the very beginning the
ogs
the day ones um you might remember we
started off with a few uh video episodes
early in the run and then we kind of
like
you know the rhona happened and they
were like goddamn no one's got time for
this and no one's got
no one's got the understanding but now
we're back we're bringing it back so
if you're listening to this on an audio
podcast
firstly what you're doing i get all the
times
head on over to youtube.com gamespot so
you can watch the video and see if
i'm kidding maybe they're driving maybe
they're driving
watch video pull over wherever you're
going is not that important
pull over make sure your handbrake is up
fire up the video and watch it on the
video we're putting it into video
anyways that was that that was just our
way of saying that we're trying to
we're thinking about bringing video back
in a big big way um
so make sure you check it out and you
know even if you listen on audio just go
over to the video
um click into it and just leave it
running in the background for between
nine
and nine and fifty minutes
you're watching on video uh maybe sub to
the
audio you know what everyone just swap
swap spots yeah everyone should
assist yeah it's a live stream game spot
game spot infinity
yeah and i like just to reiterate as
john luke said if you are watching the
video right now
why not head on over to a podcast app
and subscribe there
you might not watch it but at least our
subscription numbers go up and we can
carry on doing this bad boy
you know what i'm saying anyways uh
jean-luc you've had an eventful week
you've had new additions to the family
you've been playing
video games tell us about it uh i got
a new new friend uh a cat her name is
brinks
um she is actually uh max scoville's
old cat um they they had a baby and they
were like we don't need this cat anymore
uh
please take this cat wow i would i would
give them peppers and keep the cat
hot take hot take they didn't actually
say that but like
i i understand why that why the
exchange needs to happen because god
damn
she uh baby plus peppers plus brinks
yeah
brinks was kind of the the odd one out
so i think it was just for the best
um so we've referred to she she's a
little
we don't know her exact age um but we
think she's around 11
or 12 so she's a little lady so we've
referred to our house as her
her senior living home she's gonna come
chill with us
and just relax uh don't worry about dogs
or anything like that
uh she is so cuddly she just loves to
rub her head
on everything um i'm very
very excited about this as someone who
lives literally
doors away from you uh when i am in the
states
this this this this benefits my life as
well
um because now i can catch it for you
and i can
play with brings too immediately the
second time hurt he's like hey
you need a cat sitter guy i'm your guy
breaks brinks knows me as well we brings
and i have spent some time together as
well so
she's very very uh friendly towards
people like just um
it didn't it didn't take very long um
for her to adjust and just be like
oh like you guys seem pretty cool i'm
gonna hang out with y'all
um yeah she's been great um except for
the part where she wakes me up at three
in the morning figuring that out still
trying to set them boundaries but uh
otherwise
that's been good um and in between that
i have been playing a little
video games um oh god my brain
was like looking for the video game
music and we don't have that on this
podcast
for those who don't know i edited it i i
helped fill in on the bombcast
uh yesterday light flex um light flex i
was i was filling in for jan
and i had to like practice all their
thing of like okay like jeff's saying
like
what we've been playing i got hit the
the game music so i was like
i was like still in that mode i was like
searching for it i was like oh god
where's the
oh this small flexing
uh moonlighting
says you yeah
hey we'll get to that later
game spot what are you talking about
it's just just it's just giant
it's just giant bombs just giant bomb
now everything's giant bomb
uh yeah i've been playing some video
games i've uh i've been playing like
every 2d metroid i've been just like
going through them
um mostly because i was doing like a
video on them so i i haven't
admittedly like i played like an hour
two of each of them and kind of like
cycled through but i definitely am like
i want to go back and play all of these
because classic 2d metroid
whips it's so good like those games hold
up incredibly well
without without self-reporting are you
playing these
on on your on the original hardware or
are you using other means to play them
i am actually playing them all on
original hardware um
well so uh metroid one and
super metroid i was playing on the
switch
uh with the like nintendo online
although i was using those like
uh controllers they gave you like the
like the snes and ness controller so
like
felt like i was playing the original
versions even though i'm not um
but then for uh zero mission and fusion
i have a gba consolizer which is a
device that
um you can buy it's like a modding kit
where you take like the original guts of
a gba and you put it into this like kit
and
do some soldering and all this nonsense
and then it allows you to
output that uh through hdmi to your tv
and it looks
crisp as hell so um yeah i'm using my
original
gba cartridges for um zero mission
infusion
playing on those uh yeah it's awesome um
those games in particular i i have like
a real real fondness for um
zero mission was like my first metroid
game i ever played because i never owned
a console as a kids like i only owned
handhelds
and i love that game to death i feel
like i've probably played it like 10
times or something um
and like it's still it still holds up it
still feels so
good to play um man
i i don't play some metroid you haven't
played metroid like
it's kind of shocking to me how like
those like
that that genre has like exploded and
you know like
man like metroidvania is like they're
everywhere you can like like i'm just
like i'm walking around my house and i
trip over like a new metroidvania that
someone made
and i'm like and you know like varying
degrees of quality you know i i
never beat hollow knight but i've heard
it's one of the best metroidvanias
um i'm sure yeah yeah uh
but but even then so you'd think like
you know the og's maybe like wouldn't
hold up as much
and they'd feel like dated they really
don't like they just like
everything about like the the level
design to the controls
it just feels so tight and so um
just they're masterful they're masterful
i must say you know why
people don't play the og metroids
because nintendo makes it really hard
to actually play yeah that was
that was something i asked them when we
did our uh
play for all slash e3 interview with um
the treehouse team i was like you're
releasing dread which is the canonical
next entry in the metroid series the
sequel to
fusion are you going to make fusion
available for people to play and they
were like
no no
they were like metroid 5
i don't know one two three oh yeah i
don't know her
they're like oh yeah you're gonna you're
gonna buy metroid five
what you wanna play metroid for what's
wrong with you are you crazy there's no
we have five coming out soon why would
you watch why would you want four
like mad but um i would recommend
people one fusion is very very um
uh good still like and without
self-reporting there are
many many ways to play that game uh very
easily
um uh yeah uh also samus returns 3ds
version it is sam's return oh yeah
that's the remake of two right yeah
that's the remake of two
um excellent excellent game kind of came
in at the tail end of the 3ds
life and got like forgotten in a big way
but a lot of the designs and systems and
the team behind it obviously
um is working on dread so
that is that is you we sadly you can't
play the narrative like prequel to
dread but you can play in terms of
design ethos and
gameplay experience uh metroid uh samus
returns
to get a kind of like a a primer on it
and i highly recommend it
yeah yeah so like the that's the video
i'm working on is like hey here are all
the old metroids like
which ones are worth going back to play
how can you play them
spoiler you need to own a wii u uh to
play a lot of them
uh officially um but but yeah
that's pretty much kind of what uh my
sentiment is like if you had a pick two
you'd be like for story purposes uh play
fusion
if you want to kind of feel caught up to
uh dread and then from like a gameplay
standpoint yeah play play samus returns
um
on your 3ds or however else you happen
to
play it
[Music]
nintendo nintendo this is only going to
carry on if you keep making it hard for
people to buy your old games this is how
it's going to be
no guilt about it when it comes to
nintendo like
every everyone else i'm like don't do
that but when it comes to nintendo i'm
like these [ __ ] are they don't
give a [ __ ]
about preserving their old game that's
that's that's on them
we ask on them um i'm saying but yeah
you've also been playing some final
fantasy 7 john luke
yeah i was playing i played that youth
dlc uh
we had phil on a couple episodes ago to
talk about it i don't know if i have
much
uh you feeling it
that was you know that was good i'm just
not in the booth no don't give it to him
no that was good if all the [ __ ] of
all the [ __ ] tam does like that was
like
like oh [ __ ] yo that's classy you know
what i'm saying
it's not like uh it's not like a throw
away these nuts joke but like
you know we'll we'll get to we'll get to
it
how is it because i still haven't played
it it's it's great
actually i really like it um i i think
the main
so the main criticism i've heard about
it is how like ad doesn't do much to
like progress
the story or anything and i think that's
fair but really like to me the point of
this dlc
is to establish and make yuffie an
actual likable character this time
um because i don't know how you guys
feel about yuffie but like i
was pretty whatever about her in the
original uh final fantasy vii
it's partly the fault of like she's an
optional character so she just doesn't
get that much attention
and like every time she does have
anything to say in the story it's always
like
hey i'm going to steal your mana and
then off and you're like goddamn it
you stop stop doing that like ah um
but this one is like okay kind of like
with the rest of
the remake we're gonna sort of uh
you know keep these the core of these
characters but really flesh them out and
and
and kind of give them like more more
breadth uh
in a way where it's like i you know i
was okay with barrett in
in the original seven but i loved bear
and the remake and i thought bear was
fantastic and i feel the same way about
yuffie where like
they re really lean into how she is just
like
this sort of like kid who like thinks
she's hot [ __ ]
and and just wants to like everyone to
know that she's hot [ __ ] and like prove
herself
ish big like naruto uh energy
coming from yuffie in a way that like is
it's really charming and endearing
uh so just
it did its job where i was like you know
what yeah like yuffie's cool i like
yuffie
like i'm i'm excited for more yuffie now
and which is something i wouldn't
have thought i would say after playing
the original game
um they also do some cool stuff with the
combat where because it takes place
uh like you know you want to play after
you beat the main game
they can go a little harder with some of
the enemies and they can get kind of
weirder so they have a lot um a lot more
interesting mana combinations that are
like very specific to yuffie's abilities
and so you have all these moves where
she um uses her weapon
to not only do like uh
you know like front-facing melee attacks
but you can also uh throw it and like do
like some spin magic attacks you can
use certain mana to imbue it with
different like elemental abilities
and uh do like certain like perry type
combos and then
your um your ai ally i forget his name
uh sonan sonan uh who's cool as well
he's got some like
like i don't like daddy like nathan
fillion kind of vibes to me i don't know
um he's hot he's sweaty yeah he's hot i
like him oh yeah
yeah so he he's a daddy and he steals
artifacts from zadie zone
daddy he's a he's a thief daddy
so he's drake yeah a little bit yeah
um so the
because i they didn't make him like a
full playable character because i
imagine they were like ah that's a lot
of work and
you know he's not like a main party
remember the way yuffie is like you know
so instead he is just um
you can only control him and making him
do specific
uh magic or attacks and then also you
can do this like
synchronize button where uh he'll like
mirror yuffie's moves so like uh you'll
be like all right we're gonna
synchronize we're gonna attack the enemy
and like yuffie will jump on him and
then like
he'll jump and then you just do this
like rhythm back and forth where you're
both just like
like a ninja in like just
[ __ ] yeah beating the [ __ ] out of
them it's really good it's like super
satisfying
kind of makes the game a little easy
when you do that you're like i'm just
gonna i'm
like i'm losing this fight synchronize
then we win because we're just gonna get
the [ __ ] out of them
uh but it's like really fun at the same
time like super flashy and really
satisfying
uh i i had a really good time with it
also
music i gotta say the music eufy's music
battle theme
slaps it's real it's real good
um how how long is the dlc
it's not very long it took me like four
hours um i
granted i didn't do all of the um
yes the four condor mini game i played
like one thing of it and i was like
nah i'm not feeling this i don't i don't
really wanna cause they were like
all right now you can go around and
fight all five
uh condor people and you're like uh
no i'm i'm good um
although one of them sorry
look at someone who has not played final
fantasy vii since it came out
how easy is it to jump back in and
remember
how combat works and what you're
supposed to do to actually
win that's my biggest worry it's
definitely
long it took me a minute like i was kind
of getting my ass handed to me
for like the first like you know couple
encounters and i was like oh man this is
like really hard or am i like forgetting
there's a little bit of both um like
they they're
the training wheels definitely aren't
there they kind of expect you to like
remember
how to play the game but um i don't
think it's
demanding enough that you would find it
you i think you get back in the rhythm
pretty quickly and and because it's just
two characters and you don't even have
to directly control one of them you
really can like
they they really let you just like focus
just on learning yuffie as a character
and like getting to understand how she
functions and you're not juggling all
these other characters
so um a little bit of a learning curve
but i i got into the rhythm pretty quick
did you see the story about why yuffie
was selected
as the character for the dlc over
vincent
it's cause like vince is just like
chilling in a coffin right
yeah vincent is canonically in asleep
so they were like we can't do anything
with this [ __ ] he's fully asleep
in his coffin
yeah they also had this like the villain
characters which i guess are from
dirge of cerberus i haven't played any
of the final fantasy spin-offs so i
don't know any of that
i mean they were like they were there
and i was like
all right this is some like
square kingdom hearts ass you know
[ __ ] but i'm here for it like
whatever it's cool you know uh
it was fine but i i didn't have any
context for who those people were and
they didn't really reveal much but like
i assume
they will come back in like a youthy
related thing
in part two or three or whatever yeah
i'm gonna i'm gonna check that out for
sure um it's worth it i have
yeah especially since i love the
original game
and i'm doing like a replay now that the
uh ps5 updates are out as well
um michael hoss michael hospital i
was about to say because i read what
you've done damn
i just i just it's because well i've
just read what you added to your what
you've been doing and it says two point
a hospital in real life
yeah yeah i've been i've been i spent
the last uh
three four days in the hospital
[ __ ] like damn
this [ __ ] sucks um damn so over fourth
of july weekend i
went back to san diego uh for uh
to like be with my family and be with my
girl and like meet her like meet up with
her family and all this other stuff
so i checked into the hospital on friday
to check out like my
like i have a swollen ass leg and what
is someone that has a
leaf blower in the background or
something my neighbors
i don't know they have like a dentist's
office in their like
no there's that guy who like does
woodworking outside
i always used to see him when i when i
when i used to come out and he'd have
woodworking
equipment out and he's like i [ __ ]
cut in pieces of wood and i'd be like
what are you doing could it because it
seems like an ideal time to do some wood
cutting
i'm sure no one's going to see if it's
your day job sure no he's
what the [ __ ] he's a lunatic man
sometimes i see him like you cannot be
doing that [ __ ] that's
mad because like it's ridiculous it
travels as well but he was on
he was on my side of the apartment so it
for it to be that loud
it's gotta be somewhere no i think it's
just my neighbors have like a blender or
something and they make like their
morning smoothie but they also do it at
like 10 o'clock too and i don't know
what's up with that but
yeah jake used to do that [ __ ] like 6 30
in the morning when i used to live with
jake
yeah i'm so glad he's on this podcast
anymore
just kidding now when we was not when we
was kicking it with him uh
last episode so y'all should check that
out episode 100 with ogj decker you know
what i'm saying
um but yeah i've been in the hospital
for like three four days and then so
i flew back home to be with my friends
and family turns out they're gonna have
to cut they had to come see me in the
hospital
uh and then i had like half a day of
actual vacation left over so
i [ __ ] went all out i turned up i was
like get these
get these ivs off me bro where's the
henny at just coming out of the hospital
looking like
wolverine busting out of weapon x like
with a bottle of honey in my hand yeah
california burrito in the other
just replaced the ivy bag with a bottle
of henna with head that's what i said
give me those yeah i was getting
antibiotics i want them antibiotics you
know what i'm saying
[ __ ] let's go uh please drink
responsibly
thank you yeah don't yeah also henny hit
me with the sponsorship what's up with
it
uh but yeah i so i haven't had much time
to do anything i uh like i had my switch
but i didn't really feel like playing
video games
i don't know i was just like sad um you
know
but it happens it happens man uh
i hope it doesn't happen to anybody else
because that [ __ ] [ __ ] sucked
uh and many other things that that
happened while during my stay there
but i've also been uh i have played a
game that
many many folk have been talking about
called the house
in fatsa morgana i got it right here on
switch
yeah it finally got to you natalie got
to me all right so shout outs out to my
homegirl natalie flores i feel like i
shout her out every time i'm on the
goddamn podcast but
she has good taste and i trust her on
this one
she says it's the best game of all time
and that's a lot coming from her wow
it's also apparently the highest rated
uh nintendo switch game
uh in history uh it has like 100 on
metacritics so
yeah it's got like eight perfect reviews
i think bad because it was like the only
people who reviewed it
like the only people who reviewed it are
the ones who are like yo [ __ ] is fire
because this is like a like a
definitive edition of it so of course
the people are going to play but like yo
shout from the rooftops so i get it it's
a visual novel
it's kind of uh creepy it has sensitive
subjects
it has twists and turns and apparently
it's really well written
so i'm about to find out what that's
about because i'm super interested in it
and
i i don't know i want i want to be
surprised that's another thing too is
that when i play games now it's like i
want to be surprised
by something like even like the big aaa
stuff is dope
but i feel like i've played these kinds
of games like i was playing ratchet and
clank like this is an incredible game
but
i feel like i've been here before i've
done this um and then playing mass
effect obviously playing the mass effect
remaster
these are games that i've played
multiple times before and it's a lovely
thing to have to remember replay those
games in
higher definition and much more better
quality of life
but i don't know i'm seeking things to
be surprised but i've also been playing
a fantasian which is also a lovely
surprise
in the regard of like oh this is a this
is comfort food after we've talked about
that game
uh previously but like on apple arcade i
was just like
chilling in my hustle bed like yo where
my beds at
what can i get out of here i listen to
the
the new audio art already i don't know
what else
so i pull up fantasion i'm just like oh
yo
fantation's been great so house and
fought some morgana i'm gonna find out
what that's about
i literally just started it this morning
i bought it last night i couldn't
download on the plane
but i am gonna play it now and hopefully
this [ __ ] better knock my socks off
you know what i'm saying uh so uh yeah
y'all y'all should keep that or actually
wait till wait till i say something
and then what's the code repeat that
house of bigfoot
the house of fat morgana oh that would
oh my gosh like final fantasy 14 has the
fat cat um
plushie yeah i want i want a fat morgana
plushie oh my gosh i should be so cute
it's currently on sale on steam
yeah yeah it's 50 off on steam still oh
the game i'm like what
the flashing this plushie just did like
five seconds ago uh some special
promotion
natalie got to gabe as well uh
damn yeah
she's getting everybody dude yeah she's
she's prolific
uh this looks this looks like it could
be interesting i'm gonna buy it for
myself because you know it's a game on
steam
yeah she got to you too yeah i'll
probably
i i do that [ __ ] all the time i'll buy
as as with everyone i'll buy a game on
steam and never play it um
i'm down for that yeah i am also very
excited to
get back into final fantasy 14 because i
need something that will comfort me that
will take care of me
that'll let me know that everything's
all right and i could beat the [ __ ] out
of [ __ ]
so that's the bonfire always fun fast
before it is chicken soup for
home for the song yes for the soul
well i'm gonna well you've sold me on
the house in photo morgana which i'm
gonna play maybe i'll like stream it who
knows
[Music]
jordan what's that what you been up to
oh i'm excited
uh i've been playing doki doki
literature
club plus um
it's been a long time since i've played
doki doki lit club and that is
it's the same game if you've played it
before then you kind of know what you're
getting into
i i wrote a quick feature on how i'm
like maybe play the
pc version and not the console version
because i think the twist for
doki doki works a little bit better on
the pc version but
the new content
oh i like i don't want to spoil it but
like oh yeah yeah it's is it good it's
got me thinking it's oh it's one of
those things where there's not like
actual game play
per se where it's like you're making new
choices and seeing new outcomes it's
like literally visual novel you're
depending on the choices you make
in the game you unlock new scenes that
showcase
what uh monica and the rest of the
literature club were up to
prior to the player character
jumping into that story so it showcases
how they meet um
and how monica sets a lot of things in
motion for that game
and then it also unlocks a bunch of
optional text logs which
seem to be indicating why what happens
in doki doki literature club the plot
actually happens
i'm trying to talk about this in a way
that doesn't like spoil what happens but
it's interesting it's cool it's like an
extra
i don't know hour director's cut
hour and a half of like new story
content that's pretty interesting and
pretty cool it like up sudoki doki from
like a
three and a half four hour game to like
a five
and a half hour game and it's cool stuff
it's kind of worth it if
for no other reason just to see what the
new content is and it's easy to unlock
the stuff because
in a plus if you like if you've gone
through a scene
before you can just press skip and we'll
just skip you straight to the
next choice that you have to make so
it's like okay i don't need to see the
introduction of all
the girls again which is like a 35
minute scene
just get me to the first choice i'm like
perfect
excellence you can just rock it through
the story multiple times see all the
different outcomes and endings and then
get all the new
content really quick it's really cool
i've i
i've been i've been playing no i've been
re-experiencing that game in a very
strange way
um so you've been watching us nick
scarpino's playthrough right
i wasn't watching it i was in it oh
really i i voice
i voice yuri in that playthrough
i only saw that they were doing a
playthrough i'm like oh i want to see
you honestly
has he done yuri's route yet because i
want to see that
so they i mean like they started playing
it i
i tuned in because i was like oh [ __ ]
they're kind of funny lads are
playing um and i think like who's there
it was like
uh nick was playing that uh
who else was on there kevin was there
kevin
joey um
i think i can't remember who else was
there it was uh well there was a bunch
of kind uh
mike obviously uh snowbike mike um right
yeah and and they like started playing
it and i was watching along and
eventually they got to the point i think
it was like 20 minutes in where they
were like oh we should we should like
have
nick was tired of reading they were like
we should have other people read this
stuff out
and they ended up like there were too
many characters and not enough
uh people to read it and i was in the
chat and um
the chat was like time go in and read a
character
so i was like wow if they want me to
read a character i'll
let me know and i'll come and and joey
was like yeah jump in
so i jumped in and they were like read
for yuri and i
from that point on just did a voice like
a proper like a voice
and like committed to it i was like i'm
not gonna break character
i'm just gonna so while they were all
making jokes i'm just sitting there
silently
uh like doing my yuri voice out of this
somewhere yeah can you give a second oh
yeah what's what's up
yeah no i'm not gonna do it because i'm
not gonna do it
no no no no no no no no you re read the
when we get to listener questions you
read the listener questions and you're
you're
it's not here's why i won't do it it's
because one i want people to go and
watch the the
the kind of funny video i mean like
listen
we'll go support our friends we've got
to support the homies like it's a fun
video
and also because i can't remember how to
do it
i just did the same thing with my homies
too like we we streamed it and
everyone had their own voices we all had
like
wild accents and [ __ ] so so like i can't
i obviously cannot do
a a female voice like and i i came up
with it on the spot
so it sounds really weird when i hear it
sometimes
i was like i quickly read up on her
character arc again and like her
personality and i was like
okay so what i want to go for is like
soft and like
sweet and reserved but also kind of
raspy like
a slightly raspy voice and i was like
this is this is what i've got in my head
right now and i did it and it sounds
really
weird no it sounds it sounds like it
sounds really weird it sounds like an
anime
like it reminds me of like the animal
that would be voiced in an anime like
sounds really odd you're like this is
anime kermit the frog what's going on
um so like since then i assume they're
gonna do a part two and yuri
is in that but like i was like since
then i've like watched a couple videos
on how to do
like a decent female voice and i'm
trying to like
get it a bit better so when i get back
there i can do a better version of it
that was funny
this is my big move into voice acting i
mean like the actor
i i stud i studied acting and drama for
like
five years in school and then i was like
all right peace i'm gonna do
[ __ ] law school and then you use
that one yeah i mean like i that was
originally what i wanted to do as a
career as well like my
my teacher then was like you should get
into acting directing because you can do
it
and i was like you you don't know what
the pressures of a south asian family
are do you
uh but yeah uh so jordan the other game
you've been playing is uh
death's door yeah uh got
hands on with the demo for that game um
which honestly was if i'm guessing
correctly is actually a pretty
hefty chunk of the game uh because
it's this game where you're playing as
this cute little crow who uh
goes into work one day like just a
little pitter patter he's got this like
tiny little glowy sword on
his back and uh he's this reaper and
basically
the rule is is that like if you're a
crow
in this world you can be a reaper and as
long as you're a reaper
you don't have to die um so it's like oh
yeah i
i can be immortal as long as i just do
uh my job forever and ever and ever um
there's like a there's a deep like i
think capitalistic
mindset uh underneath all of this but
we'll we'll we'll we'll get to that but
it's one of those things like you go out
you go on assignment you're about to get
uh the soul that you're going out for
and the people tell you before and it's
like remember
you can't actually return to the office
like until you get the soul and as long
as your like
door is opened where you have to go to
get the soul you're gonna continuously
keep aging
and right before you get the soul some
guy knocks you out you track him down
turns out it's a crow who like decades
prior
got like a similar assignment and he
lost his souls he's just been aging for
like the
past a few decades and he's basically
stole your soul to try to open this
other
door where his soul went after and he
throws the soul
doesn't open the door and he's like well
[ __ ] that didn't work
well now you're kind of like in the same
boat i am if you want to like
get your soul you're basically gonna
have to open this door and you're gonna
need like three super powerful souls to
open it go kill these uh three
giant people who have like learned to
live for a very long time and escape
death um i'm just gonna sit here because
i know that you can do the work for me
and get
my soul back so that i don't have to age
anymore
so you're telling me this is a soul's
like
dorsals
kind of but in the sense that like when
you die you don't like
lose all of the souls from people that
you've
uh collected you lose some of them if
you die multiple times in a row but you
don't
have to like go to the spot where you
died and collect everything that you did
so it's like when you die provided you
had enough souls it's like okay cool i
died i respawned at the last checkpoint
i'm just gonna go ahead and quickly
upgrade my
stats right here now with all the stuff
that i accrued over the past
20 minutes and then just keep going
going and going there's no like
frantic nerve wracking am i going to
make it back to the boss that i died at
to collect my souls
before i lose all of them again and i
just lose like
60 out 60 minutes of work
so coming out of e3 this was the
game on everyone's lips like death
stores gonna
is basically if we had to assign game of
the show to any game it would easily
100 without a shadow of a doubt be alden
ring but then shortly behol
behind that would be that's though um
does this game does this seem like
firstly what is it about this game do
you think that people
are kind of really is really exciting
them and does it feel like based on the
preview that you've played
um it has the potential to be something
special this year
uh i think for people if they want to
know whether or not they want to get
into this game if you enjoyed something
like
hades which kind of did the whole
business
like take on death plus
a little bit of humor and a little bit
of sadness in the side stories
but you didn't like the fact there was a
roguelike and you lost all your progress
between
each run death store is kind of for you
you get a very similar experience only
your progress isn't being reset every
single
time you die in terms of just being
like a special game i think there's
going to be a strong
console exclusive for xbox
um i don't think it's going to be on
game pass though
which is a shame because i think it
would do very well i can't remember
off the top of my head but i feel like
it's not i think it's only just
coming out on xbox and pc uh
but dope game awesome getting great
music
great visuals very melancholy with a
little bit of humor
one of the characters you meet is a dude
named pothead
and he has a pot for a head
and he's kind of like uh
this dude who's like hey i got like soup
up here do you like
you want some he like tries to spill his
head over into the bird's mouth and
birds like no that's
it's [ __ ] gross and disgusting please
stop like it's a funny game it's an
aw it's like charming and like the
cutest possible way and i think it's
gonna be a game that takes
maybe seven to eight hours to complete
maybe so it's like it's one of those or
it's like oh i
i don't want to play a 60-hour
assassin's creed adventure game i just
kind of want to play a game that i can
or do you beat like no
no one wants it no one wants it we're
going to get to that later but no one
actually wants that
uh i i adore games that i can look at
i'm like i can see the end point like
within the
first three to four hours of playing
yeah
uh it's worth pointing out that this
game is developed by acid nerf which is
a very small team from manchester in the
uk
big up and you may have
played one of their previous games it
was called titan souls
um which came out a whole of
years ago at this point it's like 2015
or something like that um
but another great game um but like there
they're a couple of i think there's two
developers that then collaborate with a
bunch of folks around the world
um and yeah uh looks looks really really
cool
um i'm excited for that game so so much
it's it's still it's the game that i'm
most excited for right now this month
yeah not not long ago
comes out the same day as chris tales uh
it's fine it's fine i'll play them all
yeah you'll find the time you'll find
the time
i i have downloaded a bunch of games
that i'm i'm supposed to be
playing during my break but which i'm
currently on but
i'm not doing breaks good you're on your
break
why are you here yeah baby
um i downloaded uh dothramatic
which i wanted to play um and
uh i also downloaded uh umirangi
generations
um which i wanted to check out um hell
yeah
uh and yeah and there were a couple of
other games that also i wanted to check
out but i can't
then the names escaped me now um but
i've been mostly spending my time
playing um a mass effect legendary
edition
um which is uh i'm
uh chicory is the other one that i
wanted to play um yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah and backbone chicory backbone
off i forgot about backbone
hell yeah so i think like they're a
bunch of short games so i think i might
just like stream them
and like that will be my way to force
myself into playing games that aren't
valerent um but i am enjoying um
uh mass effect legendary edition i'm
like most of the way through i'm like 30
hours into mass effect 2
just before i to just before i have to
go to get the uh reaper iff
thing uh really um
yeah i've been kind of taking my time
with it but also
it's weird because i'm taking my time
with it but i'm also like not paying a
hundred percent attention to everything
that's happening
um during the combat sequences i kind of
tune out i usually i'm watching like
hassan [ __ ] stream in the background so
like
when when when like uh when like the
combat stuff starts happening i'm
tuning out of that and i get to watch
him scream at his chat for
extended period of time and then when
someone comes up with some dialogue i'm
like okay i'll pay attention here again
and it's been nice it kind of like helps
me with like many people these days i
feel like i always need to be doing
three things at once
um to maximize my time which which is a
habit i really need to break
uh i really struggle with just focusing
on one thing like i can
i've been doing it with castlevania like
the newest season i watch one
episode and try my best to focus on
nothing but that episode but inevitably
i'll like pick up my phone and answer
any email i've got problems
but um yeah that game mass effect 2 is
really really cool really good like
super super cool um i at some point
yesterday i switched
thane to one of his dlc outfits that i
had never used in the original version
of the game
and he just like these [ __ ] glasses
and it is it turns that game it turns
that game
into a comedy game because you got like
the maddest [ __ ] happening and then like
every single scene
thane is in the background wearing the
glasses looking like the deal with it
meme
every single time the amount of like
harrowing
like the amount of time morden's been
talking to like um
uh his protege i forgot what the the
other um
hilarious name and they're talking about
like they're
they're like verbally jousting about uh
you know
the the rights and wrongs of the
genophage and thanes just in the
background
all the light is just like bouncing off
his shades and he's just standing there
like
yeah he's just looking like he's looking
like he's a frog
that fell out of the matrix universe
just like standing around
like i'm like [ __ ] i i already like
thane was already my favorite character
of
of the mass effect franchise and with
those shades
it's just it's just he has a so good now
he's ascended into like his drip is
unbelievable
i wonder if oh you he probably won't be
wearing it in three
like during the most saddest moments oh
my god
you definitely could with mods on pc
yeah the mod scenes are actually really
legit
now on that uh yeah like that that mod
has been going
wild they have um this thing called like
mod manager that's basically like this
like really easy program where you just
download any mod put it in and it just
auto installs it for you i was messing
with follow games
yeah yeah that's amazing um there's like
you can like
do a first person mod um
where you can just walk around in first
person it doesn't work for combat
switches back to third person
but it's like kind of cool because it
just turns all of the hud areas until
these like um
these like walking sim through like the
citadel
uh and like due to someone adds like vr
support
that's awesome that'll be amazing
um but yeah i've been playing a lot of
that i've been taking a lot of like
photos as well
and for mostly pictures of thane
honestly like a lot of pictures of
things
um i started off being like oh i'm gonna
take a really artful
photo of every crew member and every
like major character
and then quickly abandoned that because
i saw thane with the glasses and i was
like i'm
100 committed to this man and his and
he's like weird glasses
um but yeah that that that game the
writing holds up really well
there are some lines that are like
jaw-droppingly good
in the franchise and they come up with
frequency
in in in this uh in this game like i
finished up
yeah i've been like doing the loyalty i
like stacked up all the loyalty missions
and i'm just going through them one by
one
um i just did i did samaras yesterday
uh and so good it's real good
i was like you know what i was like you
know what this time i'm gonna i'm gonna
go with morin
and then i did the loyalty mission and
the whole experience with morin
happens and i was like [ __ ] month no
back to samara um and yeah now i'm just
uh
yeah uh i'm doing what am i doing i'm
doing
not the arrival dlc the one with the uh
uh
overlord i'm doing overlord right now um
so i'm going to finish that up and then
probably
do the uh relay and
pick up the other good character in this
in this uh game but um yeah beyond that
playing a bunch of valorent
still uh swings and rounds abouts with
that game last week i thought i was real
good this week i felt like pure trash so
we'll see how we're doing
uh that's that's the valerian experience
yeah that's the valance
that's the that's attack shooter
experience but that's pretty much it
experience yeah yeah and then and then
like in between now i'm like watching
um um berserk i'm trying to catch up on
my hero academia
uh castlevania um i started watching bob
burnham's
inside and found it it's a little boring
i find it quite boring oh i was just
like never mind
is it too is it uh i asked you this
before but is it is it
too uh jacobian it's very yakubian it's
very very accubean and like i can
understand
some of the like i can relate but like
i think singing comedy doesn't work for
me at all
yeah um or even singing because like the
jeffrey bezos song is stuck in my head
but like and the things that he's saying
are like
impactful but like they're not
especially astute observations
he's not saying anything that anyone
else hasn't
tweeted already like it's just he's
saying it
so like now it's getting way more
attention and he's singing it and
singing comedy doesn't work for me at
all i found like
i and that that combination i'm like
halfway through it because i keep coming
back to it in chunks
and i feel like the production is very
impressive i'm super super impressed
with that like
the fact that it's a one-man production
and the amount of effort that's gone
into that and he's clearly pouring his
heart and soul into it but it's like
everything he says is
yeah i've seen someone tweet that the
production is like what really like drew
me into it
personally like like i was sitting there
like oh like how's he doing this does he
have like a
you know uh like like what kind of rig
does he have like what kind of light
systems he using like i was like really
trying to like pick
apart like exactly my man's got arms and
legs and that's all he's doing
he's got using them he's putting them to
work
i mean like like i said like i i'm like
halfway through so i think like the
latter half kind of really really gets
better i will say like the first
one of the first things he says is like
can everyone just shut the [ __ ] up and
not say something about
everything constantly and i was like
yeah that's that's a
that is like a big 2020 2021 mood
everyone feels the need to always say
something about everything that is
happening on the internet constantly
and like his the way he like it boils up
in him and it just like explodes into
just the most like aggressive just
everyone shut up
everyone shut up i was like i can relate
to that i get it
but excuse me while i go and tweet now
about the latest thing that happens
uh but yeah so that's that's pretty much
it
um let's move on to news because we've
got some
absolutely fascinating stories to cover
sean luke
hit the news music oh
one sec the news music broke
you're dropping the ball john you'd love
to see it hold on wait no wait i got it
i got it i got it i got it i got it
right back run it back right back hit me
again
jean-luc hit the news music
god damn what the [ __ ] you know what
should i look uh we're gonna have a
meeting after this oh oh
you played for a sec ah man hot second
goal technical
technical technical difference one more
time one more time come on okay we got
it we got it
here we go
that's enough of that let's head over to
the news we've got some fascinating
stories jean-luc
hit the news music first time
never doubted you for even a second
nailed it the first story
comes from a little company called uh
you may know them as nintendo they used
to make hanafuda cards now they make
marginal improvements to hardware you
love
michael yo what's up
what's going on with the deal the
nintendo switch and why have they
allowed samsung to rename this device
like what is this this looks like some
the nintendo switch oh led looks like
some
in lg executive got into their branding
department stupid name
we want that switch
you know that classic from waka flocka
that's probably what they were thinking
about
oh nintendo switch oh let's do it okay
so this is your taxes
to make the the the the nuts joke that
you want to make
no it's not in there that's that's you
know it's not is that like okay
okay i've already made that joke on
twitter it got mad likes you know i'm
saying follow make sure you follow your
boy for more of these nuts jokes
so um nintendo bust out and said we're
gonna put a seven inch screen
on this thing up from 6.2 keep it the
same size so there's less bezels
i'm a huge fan of that that's what i
want uh and it's uh you got a wider
adjustable stance so shout out to
jeff baklar uh so you can review that
stand if you want i know it's a sore
spot shouts out to you my boy
but it will not feature any performance
improvements or 4k
support and it will sell for 350 bucks
released on october 8th
the same day as metroid dread so look
here's the thing right y'all feeling
this or not
like most of us who have lived in the
pandemic
like we're going to come out of this
with no performance improvements as well
so like
as as another creation within the
pandemic i'm not at all surprised that
this is just the same thing
a bit like marginally improved um
but i am i i tweeted about this i was
like
this is this is this is clearly not for
me this is clearly
not what i want out of it am i gonna buy
it absolutely
you know why because because when it
when it's approaching people are going
to be talking about there's going to be
pictures
i'm going to get hyped and then i'm
going to buy it and then when i have it
it's going to give me that little rush
of endorphins and you know what
we live in an age where we should take
the opportunity if you can
if you have the means to to just savor
every endorphin rush that you can get
via a reasonable 300 bucks though yeah
i think i'm about to get an endorphin
rush yeah i mean i'll i'll sling some
old [ __ ] and get
get you know yeah i'll trade in the
office switch that i use and then uh
i'll pick this one up so
thank me later uh i'm so good i'm
i'm i'm into this like uh i i want a
bigger screen with
less bezels uh and
yo that that white and the black and
white colorway
it's pretty good say less yeah let's
miss that you gotta get this
five in the xbox series s you get the
whole white setup
got rounded edges it's got an ethernet
port built into it
uh and that's that on that so
you know what folks were like clamoring
for like an improved version that had 4k
in it like
that and that that's not happened now
maybe it'll happen still happen later
but
that's not what this is i think i i
think the the
the the company nintendo that has uh
put out uh what was it like 8 000
different versions of the 3ds
i am not at all doubting that they will
have another version of this console
that is more powerful and
i have like a tiny ibm thinkpad style
knob in there on something like that
like
in the same way that they did for all
the other three years we've had the 3ds
we had the 3ds xl we had the new 3ds we
had the new 3ds xl we had the 2ds we had
the 2ds xl
uh [ __ ] man and we had like how
different
special editions too like come on this
is the thing that i want
i i am waiting with uh baited breath
for a metroid dread version of this this
switch if they do a switch or led
metroid dread version
day one like i'll be there people were
kind of pointing out the color scheme
kind of does match metroid red that like
the white matches like the robots and
then they got the classic blue and red
and the smashing samus i mean yeah i
know what you mean but like yeah i want
samus's
face on there yeah i want i want this i
want samus's face in there i want i want
the
metroid logo on there and then we're in
business we'll pop in
you do that for me nintendo i'll give
you another 50 i'll pay 400 for it and
i'll be ashamed of myself for doing it
i'll do it
yeah mostly people play handheld though
like
if you play mostly docked there's
literally nothing
for you to gain from this yeah that's
kind of where i'm at like i
i i don't play um handheld this often
and and also i think a big part of me
and i'm like still kind of holding out
hope that like
an eventual pro revision will do this is
like i
really need new versions of the joy cons
because they yeah they'd be giving me
carpal tunnel they'd be giving me like
all the handcrafts like it's uh
i was never a fan of the the sticks the
analog sticks these analog sticks are
awful
like and i get that they were probably
like look we can't change too much
we got to keep the you know it kind of
splits the ecosystem up
and and maybe first saw a version that's
not too
substantially different it wouldn't make
sense to do it uh but yeah i'm like i
really need
something something new and improved uh
for that i think that would have been
the thing that actually like super sold
me on it right now i'm seeing it and i'm
like
yeah like this stuff's all right but
it's not enough that i'm like clamoring
for it how's nintendo uh
fixed its nope data transfer
problem like the reason i like buying
multiple playstations and xboxes is
because i'm like oh i can have one here
i can have one at my parents house i can
have one
at my partner's place and like i just
log into my account and just all my data
is there just obvious
everywhere fix that or no it feels like
i feel like a really convoluted process
for this if you're if you're starting a
sentence with has nintendo fixed there's
a 99.9 recurring
percent chance the answer is being
hopeful
no don't i like the for me it's
it's i i am actually excited about this
because i am one of those people who
does play handheld
you know i hand hold these nuts that's
what i'm saying
uh next story comes
from uh a little company who
is known as ubisoft uh
jordan what is going on with uh
assassin's creed infinity what is this
wait assassin's creed what
no no no no no no no
you know the vibes all right continue
jordan back to back these nutshots
let's go who knows what's up what's
happening with assassin's creed right
now
but uh right before ubisoft made the
official announcement uh jason schreier
uh
came out with a report being like hey
yubi's going in changing direction with
assassin's creed again they've gone from
open world adventure to rpg now they're
going from rpg
to live service
something and uh it's gonna be take
place
on the same platform but like just
multiple settings it's just gonna evolve
like taking inspiration from games like
fortnite
and uh grand theft auto online uh
and then ubisoft like i want to say like
an hour and a half
after that it was pretty quick release
the
official announcements like yeah we are
actually
doing that it's gonna be a cross studio
thing between uh montreal and quebec
uh we still have the super problematic
uh men in high positions still in those
high positions working
on this but we're hoping that you
overlook that and get excited at the
possibility of assassin's creed becoming
so stupidly large that it just lasts for
[ __ ] ever
oh my god this is so stupid
the thing is like i i said i said
something similar on twitter where i was
like i
was hoping they'd get smaller because
i'm very much in the same
camp as many of you are especially
jordan like i want
smaller tighter more detailed more
controlled narrative tales and they are
going the opposite direction
and i had a few people like kind of
replying some people being
twitter people being like shut up no one
cares what you think um but other people
being like uh you know they they kind of
pointed out that you know they have
they're kind of mentioning that they
have the capacity to make those smaller
tails within this larger framework
yeah and that i i really want to get
behind the idea of that the problem that
i
foresee or the one that i can't get past
is
modern game design requires you to
to requires developers to like author
and construct these pathways
that take you to every corner of this
massive world otherwise it's pointless
having a massive world
and the way they do that is they create
these bread crumbs that are constantly
moving you from one thing to the other
and pulling you in multiple different
directions so that it never feels like
you're done
that's how these games as a service
games work right you never feel like i'm
done
this is it i've got a short tail i
experienced a complete narrative
it's always something there's always
something happening and so that's my
main worry about it sure they might be
able to tell these
tales smaller tales but will they be
able to resist the temptation of always
funneling you into another thing
or wasting your time with me in your
tasks that ultimately have no bearing on
what you're actually doing from a
narrative perspective
that's my main worry i have two minds of
this i'm
i have no basis for my
beliefs theories as to what ubisoft is
as to what ubisoft is going to do but
i'm like either
hey they do something like what they
were teasing at the beginning of
assassin's creed unity where you like
logged in and you saw like a bunch of
different
experiences yeah click from and it's
like oh this is a portal you boot up
assassin's creed
infinity and it like it starts with like
one
default uh campaign or maybe it's free
to play and then
like each campaign is like twenty
dollars here for like this experience
and maybe forty dollars here for this
much longer one and
etc etc etc or if they are
leaning more in towards what something
like
fortnite what grand theft auto online
does
it's a giant like open world
modern day assassin's creed where
occasionally over time the world
is evolving and at the same time you
have like an animus you can
visit that uh you can use to do a bunch
of
single-player content in the past but
like in the present day it's like this
open world multiplayer experience where
you can participate in different
activities other people like
bring back the multiplayer from
brotherhood and three
okay okay siege things from unity stuff
like that and i'm like i could see it
going either way i could see it doing
something completely
different students they bring back the
brotherhood multiplayer i'm
in yeah i feel like i feel like that's
exactly what they have to do because
they talk about how it's going to have
multiple settings
and there's no cohesive way to make that
work in a
a kind of like seamless open world right
like you have to
i feel like it's going to be very much
that that case of like
the the main world is you know an
abstergo like facility in a modern day
where you are a bunch of subjects
just and then you can pick and it's kind
of like
you drop in with all your friends and be
like all right let's go to
i don't know italy and then you all jump
into the animus together and it'll take
you all to
i don't know ac brotherhood's
multiplayer mode or a a curated
experience that is a unique
assassin's creed 2 setting or you know
black flag setting etc etc
i i would struggle to see how they make
a a
a larger experience that has multiple
settings cohesive
outside of hey there's a portal here
jump through it assassins
and then you come out on the other side
and it's like oh you're in another part
of the world now
cowards will refuse to make a single
player game starring a woman
in assassin's creed they just won't do
it i just won't
do it something
i found interesting about the ubisoft
statement specifically is that
they when they were talking about it
they were talking about it less from the
perspective of
like what the game is going to play like
as a consumer and more about what that
means
from like actually developing it uh
specifically they were saying how like
they had this like new cross studio
collaboration structure
and and like they said like i'm gonna
read what they said here uh quote
rather than continuing to pass baton
from game to game we profoundly believe
this is an opportunity for one of
ubisoft's most beloved franchises to
evolve in a more integrated
and collaborative manner that's less
centered on studios and more focused
on talent and leadership no matter where
they are
within ubisoft so it kind of sounds like
this is almost like a back end thing of
like
we can build this system that allows it
to
be easier for different teams of ubisoft
across the world to like
build their own assassin's creed game or
story and like
have it easily be integrated rather than
like having like you know
a bunch of different teams like building
multiple assassin's creed games at a
time and they gotta kind of
talk to each other with call of duty
exactly because like
activision ran into that problem where
you had like you know infinite warfare
and black ops and
they tried to fuse them together and it
like totally didn't work because those
are games are built on like different
engines and was kind of a mess and i
think ubisoft's like
we can avoid that by like building this
system from the grout up to support this
yeah like if you think about how a lot
of when ubisoft
where with assassin's creed how it gets
like handed off from studio studios like
a lot of stop and go stop and go
in terms like this studio is going to
make odyssey this studio is going to
make origins obviously they had they
have had collaboration when i
was like talking to developers about
odyssey they're like yeah this has been
long development because we work
alongside the origins team
uh to make sure that these games are
like
congruous they're not like just like
these completely separate experiences
that don't make sense
when you connect them together so i
think this is more of like a
framework for them to kind of
communicate how they're approaching
stats and screen
but if it's if it feels more continuous
i also think that
i mean i can't speak for y'all but
assassin's creed based games are long as
[ __ ]
and i never almost finished them
recently no but they come out
but they come out but they come out with
really good dlc or they
they have like the their dlcs are chunky
and
are like oftentimes
yeah they're like whole other games but
like no one like i imagine that
fewer people play those because they're
like yo i'm i'm done with this like i'm
not like what is this dlc i'm gonna buy
it for a game that i already bought
uh because now the mentality is the
expectation is to have
like if dlc is part of is packaged with
the game that you already bought or
something or it's an update
to something that you subscribe to uh or
something something like that and
so i think that this this framing will
help those at the add-on content to kind
of like string you along
to the next assassin's creed game like
fate of atlantis like what what was that
like oh that was actually pretty fire uh
i don't know i didn't i didn't
i didn't get to it but if it's like a
30-hour dlc
yeah and then so but like i didn't touch
it but if i boot up a screen like oh
snap like
this i don't know i feel like it's just
a lot more seamless for
as a player and i imagine this can also
help them
be a lot more um i think more efficient
when it comes to like
making these games yeah i think there's
a lot
i think i i wish they would sit down and
really unpack the
the knock-on effect of having the games
be this
large because for me i think one of the
biggest issues i have is like
because they're this large i do not give
a [ __ ] about the main characters i'm
incapable of caring about those
characters
because one the idea of playing a 70
hour game
where a significant portion of that game
is you
running boring errands and doing like
random side [ __ ]
it just it doesn't endear me to a
character it makes every every character
in assassin's creed modern assassin's
creed even like
um bayek is like you aren't really an
assassin you're an
errand you know you're an errand boy
aaron girl you're a
yeah he's i mean a bayek was
specifically a cop but like even like
cassandra like cassandra i was like
i want to care about you but you keep
running off and doing this
boring [ __ ] for a really long time and i
just cannot
like the last character in assassin's
creed that i really cared about was
probably
i don't know edward kenway like yeah i
was into him
but like none of them come in eevee and
syndicate
no not really because there was two of
them and i like i didn't really like the
back and forth between them like i want
to go back and give syndicate another go
honestly i kind of bounced off of them i
found them quite annoying
um but i think i was in a very irritated
phase of my life as well there where i
was just annoyed by
everything um but like i
i wish i could care about a character
the way that i did care about like
altair
and and and uh or even like the
the uh modern day stuff like i don't
know what the heck was going on with all
that
and it's like it's the same problem
where it's even more so because you're
like okay you
introduced the modern character and then
you play 40 hours of odyssey and then
you cut back to the main character and
i'm like i
remember their name or what they were
doing or what's going on like
so if they can like is it couch that
lately yeah hassan yeah
yeah i like that that's one interesting
good thing about
valhalla is the fact despite its
campaign being like
70 hours and to get like the true ending
you have to spend like another
20 on top of that for like a 90 100 hour
experience
is the fact that it like references
every single mainline game that came
before it and it just
wraps up all of those story lines so
altair
uh ezio connor edward arnold
jacob evie just all of bayek uh
cassandra
and basically it's like all right put a
lid on it it's done
we've wrapped everything up we even
touch on desmond a little bit and we
kind of complete that
we are now basically at fresh slate we
can go
okay we're new from that actually
makes me a little excited yeah that is
exciting but like
that exciting is immediately dulled by
knowing that
the next step isn't a isn't a like
really smart reset where they curate and
finally craft a new character and world
it's this
platform that they've created where
anyone can be an assassin and you can go
anywhere and do anything it's like no i
was hoping you'd use this opportunity to
be like
yo we've got an assassin's creed too
like we've got we've got to come up with
a brand new assassin
we've focused it down you're going to
love this character it's going to be
really cool
it's it's not that like they're like all
right we're making fortnite or we're
making gta online i'm like i don't
really care about that i don't
yeah yeah i want i want memorable
stories
yeah jason schreier's report and the
official ubisoft uh press release
doesn't mention this but
trier's report mentions that like the
soonest we're getting this game is
2024 so three years
from now and so there's a possibility
that we get some sort of assassin's
creed experience between now
and this i'm keeping like fingers
crossed for a super like modern day
remake of assassin's creed one
but like it'll be interesting to see do
do we get
any assassin's creed between now and
infinity or is infinity just like what
happens after fall hall and we just take
a break from assassin's creed for like
three or four years
there's also no guarantee that this
infinity project actually makes it to
release like they were
they've been very upfront in that
they're talking about it like
this is something we're experimenting
with and we're figuring out
whether it happens or not is isn't a
dead certainty they might get you know
a ways into development and think this
is not working and then so we get
something else instead
it seems like the plan is to work on
that while working on um
valhalla dlc and maybe if we're lucky
we'll get a
another game in between i don't know
like i would love to see
a good remake come on i mean like
a style of re2 and re3 remake like just
completely
like up end with bring back the stealth
thing
bring back i mean like they did a bit of
that with revelations right where you
could go
back and play some of the alter stuff
but like i want them to make the
assassins creed they sold us in the
original assassin's creed
trailer from e3 like the the
that trailer still is one of the best
yeah and
that game that the game that came out
absolutely did not
make good on anything that happens in
that trailer
yet yeah but it's there now you can make
it make your
assassin's creed one hitman game and
let's go
god that'd be so cool modern
mod uh it turns out that the next
assassin's creed is a a
modern almost futuristic uh game and it
stars a new assassin named uh
samuel fisher yeah let's
go and it's awesome i would sell game
yeah
yeah i mean like i would love that i
have been thinking a lot about spending
so like
i want um if you if you want more split
a cell chat
go to the uh nuclear french podcast
assassin's creed
just a splinter cell game so that would
just be
no no no no no no no like
is one of the lead creative directors so
yeah we're definitely not getting an
actual splinter cell
for a while probably if ever rip
but you know it's going to come in as a
live service game
all their franchises i was thinking
about this earlier like i
and there is a way to make a splinter
live service game that works
but i was thinking about this earlier
but i really miss like triple a or even
double a stealth games there's just none
of them around right now that i
care about like there's no metal gear
there's no
splinter cell there's no thief there's
no
i feel like the last one dishonored how
was that game it was by like
x uh hitman devs rob hanley like loved
it
uh echo echo echo i feel like echo was
like the last game that
that game's very different obviously but
it was last game that was like trying to
be like a proper
stealth game that i can think of yeah
but like on the
like i know there are a bunch of indie
stealth games but like
very few of them have like a charismatic
central character
you know the way that we have like snake
or sam
or emily or corvo you know that kind of
that's what i yearn for another one of
those
and like okay together games industry
give us a good stealth game again
anyway let's let's move on to listen to
questions
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh that beat is nasty yeah
[Music]
it's like i get tech nine dropping some
balls at the top of that
too much i feel like for emails though
yeah for emails it's like
where we're about we've opened the door
to
a hell and we're going to pull out some
emails
we've got one question today um jordan
can you read the question please
before we do that actually i should i
should point out that if you want to
send in questions
you can email after dark podcast at
gamespot.com
or join our discord if you want entry to
the discord
all you have to do is send me your
social security number your address
your bank account details and i will
get back to you within two to three days
about that um or you can dm me there uh
on and uh on twitter um and or dm lucy
uh and i will get you in uh don't
actually send me your purse don't dox
yourself
that was a joke um jordan can you read
the first question that comes from maria
aka serious business
uh my mass effect legendary cash is
is arriving tomorrow and i can't wait to
put it on the one one scale in seven
helmet
and run around my house with nerf guns
pretending i'm commander chef
what's the dumbest gaming related
purchase you've ever made
oh this is that's easy i mean i do have
that helmet
and it was probably the most recent
dumbest purchase
i have ever made the most the dumbest
purchase i've ever made was the day one
edition of
the xbox one that came with the giant oh
sad and like i was like you know what
they were
uh messaging was poor but xbox had a
great 360 era i'm sure that they will
not
uh bugger the xbox one i can definitely
do this
and not ps4 that was i was you thought
stupid stupid decision i uh
i imported a japanese like deluxe copy
of uh
persona 3 dancing and persona 5 dancing
before uh
it got like announced for america and
then i i still haven't even
opened it because they laid out so for
america and i was like well i don't
it'll just sit on my shelf and look look
cool
there's a period i've talked about this
before but there was a period where i
just decided i was gonna
rescue gamecubes like i felt real bad
about gamecubes
just being like [ __ ] getting you're
gonna be like just getting version
yeah basically so i'd like every now and
then i'd walk past this uh
this secondhand uh game store um in the
uk and i'd pop in there and see if there
are any gamecubes and if they were like
cheap enough
i'd just buy them and be like i'll
rescue you
and like give them to someone who who
who might
who might be able to like you use like
uh give them to like
friends or like whatever if i knew
anyone like oh my friend has this
younger brother or cousin that likes
games i'd be like here's the gamecube
give him the gamecube he's got a copy of
mario kart double dash in there and and
mario
sunshine don't play mario sunshine
though um and here's melee
and like it'll be like that kind of
stuff but like i ended up
accumulating far too many gamecubes um i
still have a couple
i still got like at least five in this
room
probably um including my orange one my
spice orange gamecube
which i stole from a previous employer
um
when they made me redundant i say my old
gamecube broke so i might buy one of
those from you
so dude if you want if you want a
gamecube i'll bring it up
actually now i'm in the uk i'm not i'm
not coming back to the states
if they let me back there's also
gamecube really good third-party
uh devices out there that allow you to
um hook up your gamecube
through hdmi right to your tv like
without needing to mod it like you used
to have to like send it to a dude he
would like cut a hole in
now you just buy a device it's kind of
expensive it's like 150 bucks or
whatever but
if you want to play your gamecube on
your nice 4k tv looking sharp well i'm
gonna have to because nintendo won't let
me play any of my gamecube games
metroid prime baby you get metro prime
on that oh still bangs
it's still a good game metroid prime is
so good
so i don't think i i don't think i have
any dumb game related purchases because
i'm not a dumb person i might not be
smart but i'm not dumb no regrets
uh yeah i don't know i've probably done
some dumb [ __ ] well i always do dumb
[ __ ]
like final fantasy 14 like near the
beginning of it excuse you
oh no like eventually it became a good
purchase but like
in the beginning like it it was not a
smart
no that game was not on my radar until i
met ben jenkins
so okay uh yeah i didn't get into until
early early 2019 is when i fell in love
i found true love with uh final fantasy
14 and now we're married so
that's that on that um i don't know i
don't really buy special editions of
things
um especially not anymore because uh any
game i want to play i could probably get
game codes and if not like i don't mind
dropping 60 bucks on it
because i rarely buy games but like i
used to i used to drop mad money on uh
like tech [ __ ] i bought like how many
keyboards how many mice
i had like a wireless keyboard and then
i had oh i want a mechanical keyboard
and then i got a cheap mechanical
keyboard
and then i got an mmo mouse i didn't
play mmos at the time but that should
look tight
and then i got like a new logitech mouse
but not logically came out with a new
mouse i don't want that one
i got like mad headsets i had like seven
headsets only got two ears
uh it's there is i think i think that i
think uh
i think tech products is more uh where i
i fell into
fell into a bunch of dark deep
expensive holes
for special editions like i know doing
this they would probably not make as
much money which is why
they don't do it but i'm always really
sad that special editions are always
announced and released alongside
the game's launch like before i know
whether or not i'm like
yo this game is going to be like
life-changing for me i definitely want
the special edition by the time i
realized that titanfall 2 was going to
be like my favorite first person shooter
of all time the special edition for that
had been
sold out like for months at that point
i'm like why do developers not release
the special edition
like the same way that they did like
this is the game of the year edition
that comes out a year after
the game is out i'm like i would for
sure buy more special editions if they
came out several
months after i'd had time with the game
to fall in love with it and know like oh
yeah i want all the statues and helmets
and
scarfs and postcards and whatever else
comes
in this box when you think about it the
special editions are pretty dumb because
we're all like
yeah i'll drop 200 on a game i haven't
played yet i want those
it'll be really i want i want these
postcards and
i guess i guess fire yeah i guess that's
why
you know uh services or companies like
limited run games exist
but obviously they're not they're not
out there making deals with
you know ea for titanfall they're making
deals with indie developers which is a
shame but you are right
that's 100 uh on point with that like
for sure buy a special edition of
bloodborne now but like i wouldn't have
bought it when that game was first
announced and i'm like
look this is totally new from from
software i assume it's going to be good
but they've just i've just enjoyed dark
souls at this point who knows if
bloodborne
so i i don't know if i if i spell
special edition like it
yeah i i bought they they re-released
not re-released they re yet
but they re-released game bloodborne as
in like a playstation essentials uh
collection
that's called the red one i hate that no
no no no no no this is this is a
different physical one that they came
out with
but the physical one came out as yeah uk
exclusive only and it had like limited
covers that was like holly moss style
super yeah yeah yeah i do remember that
i've got yeah
i've got that i've got the god of war
one i've got the bloodborne one i think
i've got the
uh i think it's like eco collection
one of them like maybe shadow over
classes eco collection there's one more
that i have
which i'm pretty sure is like team
eco-related um but yeah
i think that's i think that things on my
desk
[ __ ]
today today's the first day we can go in
hey
let's get it oh actually no i think
you're right i think i think actually
our uh uh former gangster rob henry
might have rescued it for me and is
actually in my apartment somewhere
um legend uh thank you everyone for
listening to the 101st
episode of gamespot after dark we super
appreciate you spending your time
and lending your ears in your eyes to
listen to us
chat it up remember as we said if you're
a podcast listener
why not head over to youtube maybe give
it a little watch on there you know
boost our numbers are officially
would loved it that would be super
helpful for us um
and if you're watching a video if you're
watching the video and you enjoyed this
why not help guarantee the future of the
gamespot after dark podcast by heading
over to the
podcast app and just subscribing you
know and helping us grow a bit more tell
a friend
rate and review us on itunes hit us up
on spotify
find me on adult friend finder uh
uh jordan excuse you what have you been
doing and where can people find you
uh i put out uh previews for both uh
the death store one should be up by now
and before that did one for
tunic which if you're like a fan of
games like breath of the wild and dark
souls and
games they're all about discovering lore
and secrets and working with the
community to figure everything out that
game is for you and i got a
full interview and preview of that up as
well as
more full thoughts on death's door
and uh i i don't know
i'll probably if i don't write something
about assassin's creed i'll probably be
tweeting something about assassin's
creed at
jamermay so you can follow me over there
for that
love it uh michael where you at
uh you can find me and all of my
[ __ ] at michaelpieheim on
twitter.com
i don't know you know what i'm saying
no i do not know what you're saying but
i understand what you're saying if you
know what i'm saying feel me
yeah that's yeah that's that on that
jean luke
where can people find you you can find
me at john linksype uh
on twitter uh i've been like i said
i was on the bombcast uh
this week i actually say all that much
because to be honest i was like
super nervous and focusing on actually
making sure the production went well
um but uh yeah it was really cool to
help and fill out with them i'm actually
gonna be filling out uh
next week as well i believe um so
if you you didn't enjoy me on that then
too bad
you get a whole nother week of that um
otherwise uh i should hopefully have
that
metroid buyer's guide thing that i've
been working on spoiler alert
they're good go play metroid if you can
play them i tried games
you'd love to see it uh you can find me
on twitter tomorrow h
um i have been working on a bunch of
things in the background
if you want specifically something to
check out you know giantbomb.com
um buy a premium subscription check out
the show
born to run which is a brand new show
that has
been launched on giantbomb.com and
involves myself and danny o'dwyer
playing through every game in the
soulsborne from
software catalogue we're starting with
demon souls for the playstation 5.
and we're going to go through all of
them there's one episode so far i think
it's a pretty fun episode
um and uh yeah it's this is is
designed and created in the style of the
endurance runs
but a little more edited so that you're
not like wasting
hours and hours of your time not really
seeing much happen
and that was all good back in the day
but i feel like a lot of us don't really
have the time or the spirit to
uh have a kind of like low-key not
really entertaining
um stuff happening for significant
periods of time
uh we've created a character his name is
tuna supreme
legend um and uh yeah
uh if you don't have a giant bomb
premium subscription you can actually go
to giant bomb
youtube channel and get a cut down
version of the episode
we do encourage you to you know take our
premium subscription they're relatively
cheap so if you can't afford it it will
be great you'll be getting a lot of
content
that's one of many shows that are
launching um
have launched and are going to be
launching soon we've got the grub snack
show going up um
lucy and i are working with jeff baklar
on another show that's going to be cool
and then there's a whole bunch of other
shows in the background that are
currently
um in the either planning or production
phases
and there's going to be even more shows
like we're working in the background on
figuring
out we're making partnerships so if you
buy
a giant bomb premium subscription you
will get uh your money's worth why is
this turn into a giant bomb ad
[ __ ] out there see you next week
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you